yeah hello and welcome to this video
which looks a little bit different and
for good reason it's a different kind of
announcement video yeah I've worked a
lot in the recent weeks and month on a
new project that is going to be released
in roughly three weeks from now and as
you can already see him in this on the
screen it is some an e for against 24 we
have repertoire based on what Fabiano
Khurana has played to qualify for the
World Championship challenge against
bang no Scarlett is about to start in
roughly three weeks so the start of this
new course on chess table is basically
at the same time as they contest the
world title in London so what is it all
about it's a full black repertoire as
you can see him against one e4 and it's
based on one e5 that is Coronas main
main choice the symmetrical replied the
double King pawn and he goes form in
most cases as it happens on the top
level for the petrov against Knight f3
yes so we have the petrov as one of the
main cornerstones of the repertoire and
it is however a full repertoire against
one e4 so whatever a white player might
play against you the King's gambit or
whatever there is you will have the
recipe provided by this repertoire what
I can do is I can show you briefly what
it will look like just to have an
overview we will have okay the way the
screen is and we have nine chapters yeah
it's a bit weird what I did here with
the resolution so we would have nine
chapters here and this is the current
work in progress version it is not yet
completely finished them
be small changes based on a better test
of feedback so what do we have the
chapters that we have we have chapter
one early gambits and the text that is
lines like the Kings gambit or 2d form
gambit play you don't see that so often
on the top level in fact I think Fabian
who never caught it on the board
nobody ever dared the King's gambit or
the whatever yeah some of those the
Danish gambit this is pretty much
extinct extinct on the top level we will
see why by the way looking at the Lancia
shows why no strong player plays the
Kings game but on a regular basis for
example the second chapter will be all
the sidelines after E 4 E 5 that can be
played that are not directly gambit so
we have the bishops opening this is the
most important one to Bishop c4 it's an
entire Petra weapon and also and all the
other lines the Vienna what else is
there I am we have what what else so he
move those very rare lines to queen h5
Bishop b5 c3 or the ravages that are not
a gambit number three chapter three will
be everything that white may do after
Knight e4 e5 Knight f3 Knight f6 other
moves here like d3 and so on and it will
also feature the four Knights game this
is an important thing to mention that
after three Knight c3 declining the
petrov basically i advise to play knight
c6 and go into the four Knights game for
black i think this is just better than
playing bishop to perform and therefore
this is a full repertoire so against the
four Knights that will be very useful
also for non
oh of players if you want the recipe
against this so I have a black rabbit
why against scotch four nights and the
Spanish four nights and all the rarities
with the four nights plate so there was
four chapters are pretty much
interesting to every 45 player who does
not want to play the petrov as their
main weapon but also want something else
against all the the odd lines that are
so played quite often and then we have
five chapters that are exclusively about
the petrov which deals with the first
two here chapter five and six they deal
with 3d form that is nowadays
played mostly there are there two ways
to play there is the old main line this
is chapter six which nowadays is not
seen as very promising for white black
equalizers quite comfortably and there's
chip the five wear white clothes deform
and goes for a sideline which nowadays
is mostly played by white players if
they look for something interesting
because the old lines are not really
that exciting number seven chapter seven
is why taking on e5 and the side lines
that arises them and number eight is
taking only five the old main line with
Bishop III Bishop d6 number nine is the
modern main line was 593 so it isn't
absolutely a complete a forty five
repertoire within the petrov i am really
focused on the lines that karana has
played there are many others available
they can you have some variety there um
when i mainly focused on that one
interesting point about choosing the
petrov is not often really taken into
account of course and the main idea here
there how that idea was a device was
really what karana has achieved with the
it's fantastic how many key games he has
one in particular at the candidates but
one other thing was always very
interesting to me I have played a 45
with black for a long time now like 15
years my main weapon against e4 but the
petrov was not part of my repertoire up
until late 2017 i never never played it
but i always felt I should play it and
there's one key reason for that if you
look at databases and you prepare with
the black pieces against players who
play one e4 on a regular basis the
typical picture is let's just say you
have 100 games of that player in the
database and with e45 I mean yeah
let's say 100 it's it's it's a huge
figure oftentimes you will have less
total games but let's say you have 100
the typical picture is they have 90 to
95 games with 96 so it would be a real
no pair so on this card show weight not
and then they have 5 games maybe 10
games with the Petrov
it is just not that frequently seen and
this is basically applying to all levels
of play even like amateur play club play
or the typical or the typical opponent
that I also face yeah like I am master
players like 90% you see 96 and you
don't see the Petrov and people simply
don't have a really detailed knowledge
of it with the white pieces because if
you don't get it on the board off their
form with the Petrov you get an opening
choice and opening weapon where actually
you will very very likely know it better
because you will get it on the board
quite frequently if you do it if you
employ it on a regular basis and your
opponent will not know it
details absolutely crucial in this
opening because if white plays something
that is even like a little bit
substandard he will have absolutely
nothing in terms of an advantage and
yeah if they play absolutely totally
unambitious Lee you have even ideas to
take over the initiative that actually
applies in particular to lines where
white takes only five 103 which is the
most frequently played move it is of
course the solid opening it has a very
yes strategic and somewhat boring
reputation this is not entirely
unjustified because of the symmetrical
nature of a 45 in general however many
lines are extremely tactical where it
makes a lot of sense to know them of
course and what you also have to keep in
mind it is an opening that is a very
open in nature so if you value peace
play and generally speaking classical
values in chess it will be a good
opening for you to choose it's not the
one opening that you want if you want
crazy complication or completely
irrational positions that will not
happen all that frequently of course if
white throws the kitchen sink you you
will have some some of that as well but
it's not what you want to what you have
from the get-go so I'm an important
detail we release it on November 12 yeah
so three weeks from now it will have
video so if you know how they keep it
simple one in four worked on chasuble
you will know how it will work it's a
nice way of studying you had have a
video component which is synchronized
with the moves that you can learn in
and of course we will have this this
whole let's go to the title page we are
on 669 trainable variations so I'm
compared to the keep it simple money for
which is the easiest comparison it is
the same amount of nights and it is just
a little bit deeper
the average line depth is higher because
we have to look a little bit deeper he
was black we have in terms of
instructional word count it's also
roughly the same this is not the final
figure by the way that will very likely
go up slightly so it is so good chunk of
information I note that this is stuck
and the videos we have another video in
there just to have the page being yeah
working that there is something there
but of course we would have a video for
with with the Petrov in another form on
so yeah hope you're looking forward to
that it's a fully 45 repertoire it will
be a think of a huge interest for
players who already play 45 and want to
add to Petrov and who want to have good
weapons against all the oddities because
I mean be realistic you won't see it all
the time you will see the bishop see
force and the oddities and to have some
good lines against them is very
important on its own right if you are
new to e45 and you want to get it into
your repertoire it's a good start
because the Petrov is I think a less of
an challenge to learn compared to 296
where you have to learn the Italian the
with the scotch anthem yeah also has
boatload of other gambits that might
happen after 296 so it's an easier start
to e4 e5 and you will have opportunity
to learn all the odds
- that the Kings gambit and so on and if
you later on want to get more variety
and you can still at 296 and play
whatever ruie from the black side
whatever line you want so I think it's a
good start
or a good addition for people's
repertoire for me it was interesting
because I knew an e4 e5 on a general
level other lines and now the petrol is
an addition to my repertoire that I can
play ever think the opportunity is fine
depending on opponent and other
situations the petrol is an excellent
alternative yeah I hope you liked the
preview until teaser I would definitely
keep you updated once we are nearer to
the release date when exactly it will be
I think November 12 settled but don't
see and we will also have preview videos
for sure on the channel yeah thanks a
lot for watching this little intro this
little preview and again I'll keep you
posted
bye bye for today